[Musik]
dort wird präsentiert von toyota hybrid
cloud keine steckdose und wird trotzdem
elektrisch vom roten kreuz wieder höpfer
der lügt fest verankert der schweiz und
vertrauen respekt und an wenig da sich
die bewegung während der letzten 150
jahre geschaffen
wirtz gros der hilfswerke engagieren
sich freiwillige
[Musik]
großer applaus für die vielen
freiwilligen und alle die sich
engagieren
das schweizerische rote kreuz
bis die metern verboten neben der
familie mit lebt mehr schaffen kann sich
relativ guten zustand menschlichkeit ist
einer von der grundsatz vom roten kreuz
war sehr emphatisch zeigt sich im umgang
mit den schwächsten für sie das rote
kreuz war von gesetzen logik
vergangenheit gibt es produkte moment
menschlichkeit nur dank der zivilcourage
einzelner rot kreuz mitarbeiter nicht
ganz verdaut worden ist die haben das
gemacht was ihre feiern bevor eindruck
seite und nicht die vorschriften muss
hier berühren
rallye lehrer hat muss der geschichte
und was für eine rolle spielt
menschlichkeit der flüchtlingsarbeit vom
schweizerischen roten kreuz
guten morgen
[Musik]
märz im harz verschwitzt altdorf im
kanton uri
hier steht zwanziger asylzentrums rote
kreuz wirtschaftssteuer es noch für
knapp 100 platz hätten darin für
asylbewerber 16 verschiedenen nationen
am tag vom im zug ist zu klären
mit drin der leiter von asylzentren
coach trainer erschafft schon fast 30
jahre zurück im zentrum von hus und dass
man auch nicht
[Applaus]
taxi lang wenn man weg zum zenit der
verurteilten zu wissen dass wir nicht
schaffen mit als nicht auf einer
arbeitsleistung von dead rising ich bin
froh um so tätigkeit und wenn es nur der
sturz wehrte
hallo guten tag miteinander dass ich
wieder berichten
mit der kc und ideen assenheimer das
rauchverbot und das ist eigentlich der
regen also dass sie liefern warum ich
weiß nicht wie es ihnen oft wenn ich
könnte würde ich wenn ich die nach den
wahrlich dann war nicht mehr mit was ist
das problem frauen chinesisch sie haben
mich beleidigt
ich sage wieso sagt wieso nennt ihr
nicht hier
ich verstehe eure sprache was ist mit
dem glas passiert sie wollte weg gehen
dann für sie nach hinten noch so die tür
alles ist kaputt
wir machen uns sorgen ja aber ich mache
doch auch vieles anders als du darum ist
es wichtig dass wir einander viel besser
respektieren könnt ihr euch
entschuldigen geht das ja ich
entschuldige mich raus und sie rechtlich
aktion mitglied sprach redet dass es
nicht immer nur gut geht oder aber
schlussendlich gehört das dazu dass ich
auch zugute
jetzt machen wir den rest noch durch
cholerische begnadete mediator und man
merkt ihm an dass er gerne mit
erwirtschaftet basilika schublade seite
der fifa familie vater hat die russland
glaubt geschafft bevor dem asylzentrum
aus betreuen angefangen hat mittlerweile
ist es schon lang leiter von einem
zentrum und im ärger sofort das ist kein
großer pato 48
das klima hängt auch unter anderem das
heißt sowohl bitte mitarbeiter was habe
ich den 5 und das heißt dass mit lifou
habe sondern auf augenhöhe begegnet und
das hat damit zu tun dass man sich
nichts gutes ahnen dass grundwasser das
funktioniert jetzt in einem garten
nein das sicher nicht darf sich das ist
ja sie besitzt und sie findet dass
wahrscheinlich ich würde sagen es war
wenn ich wenn ich die frauen seien oder
nicht
die schätze dass auch 150 jahre
schweizerisches rotes kreuz willkommen
gehen wir nun da
paar stritt musikart stellte und
freiwillige helfer bundesplatz hofe zu
viel raum für größte und älteste mann
etat organisation von einem lanz wieder
und auch lässig sein
[Musik]
lernen sie die rotkreuz familie noch
besser kennen und tauschen sie ausmachen
sie freundschaften
[Applaus]
aus schweizerisches rotes kreuz ist mit
dell vom größte humanitäre zwar verwarnt
[Musik]
würden sie daher vor wie der hobby für
mich zur familie von rot grün
das ist böse familie
manche
[Musik]
vielleicht doch
das rote kreuz höhere identifikation war
motiviert die sätze für die etwas nicht
gut geht wird aus sind stiftenden funde
[Musik]
seehunde schwächstes gründen
das ist schon sehr alt liebt sie vom
roten kreuz
[Musik]
ausgangspunkt war sichtlich 815 die
brutale schlacht von solferino
französisch italienische und
österreichische truppe kampf gegen 40
soldaten dort oder verletzt wurden
schlachtfeld liga begann
wirtschaftsrates gemetzel und ist
schockiert dass es nur um die verletzten
kümmern damit dorfbewohner organisierte
pflege für die verwundeten vorbei
exporte russen steht internationale
komitee vom roten kreuz ikrk
[Musik]
später gründete auditiv schweizerische
rote kreuz aushilfs freien für schweizer
bahnen und ihre familien
[Musik]
erst mal zum einsatz und schweizerische
rote kreuz im südfranzösischen trainiert
sie medizinisch betreut
[Musik]
im zweiten krieg ist es praktisch oder
monster regierung gestellt
krankenschwester und sanitäter um pflege
und transport vor der verwundete gründet
und auf eurosport interniert dass sie
sie zuständig sei
später trotzige zivile tatkräftigen
moosbauer und im schnitt nur mir sondern
im ausland geholfen über ständige und
andere naturkatastrophen hält zum
beispiel spannende aktionen oft weg
stellt und hilfsgüter und medikamente
braucht
[Musik]
ein wichtiger schritt für das bild vom
medizinischen personal worte
ganze generationen hält pflege vom sak
mit diplom abgeschlossen
trotz vom schweizerischen roten kreuz
waren der marke smart ist acht jahre der
direktor ein früherer das internationale
komitee vom roten kreuz geschafft und
ich war wie durch mission betritt die
einmalige chance überzeugt die kunst es
eigentlich egal was mit valmet
zufälligen ist die für die mitarbeiter
und freiwilligen ganze familie
wie machen das die satzführung für
verletzliche menschen da die solidarität
das verbindende und ich denke immer wenn
man bis macht für die notleidende
menschen den ich solidarisch aber legt
sich die kugel und die verbindet das
gekriegt
aktuell sitzt flüchtlinge wohnen
beschäftigen da wo man sich wieder mehr
engagieren
mitte letzten jahres mit die arbeit
vernachlässigen gewinnorientierte
organisation heathrow tritt im
asylbereich verdrängt im asylbereich
nehmen oder fast 53
es gibt jetzt wieder mehr automatisch
wird ein krisen hund wochenblatts
auftrag wieso fuß ich denke
migrationsbereich mit mehreren und
schweiz in der schweiz aber weltweit
noch mehr mache die flüchtlingsbewegung
die werte nur durch höhere mengen des
dauner mehr fahrbereit und wenden also
sicher vor ort auf die migration program
endgültig sind
die integrationsleistung die moderne
klar verstärkt werden
[Musik]
integration von flüchtlingen verstärken
was heißt das situationen massenweise
abspann tisch und politik mit
überforderung und abwehr reagiert wir
haben den grundsatz für menschlichkeit
trotzdem im alltag umsetzen
nein ich bin junge wächst asylzentrum
autos
[Musik]
nummer weiß auch auf ständigen rasante
karriere gemischte formation zentrum der
kunst wähler überzeugt
wie geht ist die gut danke und die nach
und sich in der sitzung vom band die von
kohl mit dem ddr- bürger bedeutet das
dass ich mich verstanden es mit dem
kanton das heißt ich und so dass
momentan die parameter haben wir ein
trio das in der betrieb staatlichen
stellen dürfe den prozentsatz bei
aktuelleren einer vertiefung der ist
wohl dass es gesetze von mozart personen
wohl nur im verfahren sind wo noch kein
scheitern
die mündigkeit user das heißt die
integrierte der integrationsprozess
allee stellen aufbauen wenn man vor
laufen oder in aller heimlichkeit
und wenn jetzt alle chrysler werke sind
dass liegt bei ärgerlich schließlich
landet wo er höchstwahrscheinlich über
längere zeit warten bis der schweiz
blieben und umso wichtiger ist dass sie
möglichst schnell deutsch lernen
okay wir machen einen kleinen urlaub für
das emsland zur heimat wird und eine
sache engagieren ist sprach wichtig aber
ohne arbeit
der ursprünglich hoch coach trainer
steht wird altdorf ihre ehemalige
domspatz das integrationsprojekt vor
im restaurant format scharfer
flüchtlinge und vorläufig noch nie
bittet daniel ruppen nach rom hieß es
gibt neue eine bestellung für sechs
personen
die brauchen sie viel in einer schüssel
nach 2012 es empfehlungen und 2 der
wollte maria markus rund aus eritrea ist
für freeski hat familie und machten uns
bilder aus hoch
[Musik]
morgen machen mit einer und grundlos
also potentielle für kosmetik zustand
ich bin zuständig für trainings sprich
eine stunde darüber
das ist schon ein bisschen schneller und
das mit der sprache geht das ja mensch
wenn er muss er auch sehr bestimmt weil
ich sage ich muss schneller und man
braucht sehr viel geduld braucht die
komplette studium oder sind sie klemmt
noch ganze stadt
[Musik]
was wäre ihr traumberuf
ich spiele alles gute aber wirkliche
ziel ist eine subventionierte betrieb
dass ähnliches - geschaffen
das stimmt ja ja das ist ja sowas ist
duncan integration oder 30 von deiner
selbst bestimmen mit gibt's nicht zum
nulltarif dass ich das alles kostet geld
das braucht fachkräfte
sie warte theoretisch geschult und
praktisch also läge die rendite aber auf
jeden fall aber wenn die leute um mich
herum trees praktikantinnen ob ich jetzt
der gruppe sind aussichten 2011 herum
deiner fans kennen im arbeitsmarkt
markieren
und wenn das der erfolg geschuldet denn
heißt dass man hin 21 personen wenigen
wo über längere zeit von der sozialhilfe
militärmusik später zum geburtstag vom
roten kreuz kirche zum militärischen
großsegel schweizerische rote kreuz
musste kriegsverwundete entstanden ist
oder dass man vor dem bundeshaus viele
passt zur regierung und den bürgerlichen
fräsen jetzt als abgänge besondere
zugang
wie geht das zusammen mit der
neutralität und unabhängigkeit vom roten
kreuz das fritz präsidentin annemarie
huber hotz evo für ihre fleißige
bundeskanzlerin auch die bundesweite
[Musik]
zusammenarbeit ist ganz ganz wichtig ein
sisters behörde verständlich verwehrt
dass wir tätig sind das mit das jahr mit
etwas doch bedürfnisse der schweiz sind
anders sieht das behörde was sie mit dem
schweizerischen roten kreuz entweder
über die nach der wahl wird es schwierig
ist schwierig für mich geben war ganz
sicher der film nicht
instrumentalisieren von der behörde oder
für politische ströme gehörte dort aktiv
sind sondern wir sind unabhängig neutral
und wir sind für die menschen da wo es
nötig kennt und nötig die hilfen vom
roten kreuz und auch einmal mit
rücksicht auf politische strömungen wenn
ich sage dass die kluft wegen hofnarr
wie das vorne weg machte das gibt auch
reaktionen
es gibt nur sagen amerika trotz
mischfonds politischen ideologien
politische richtiger wo wir die grenze
schließen und der deutschen
reiseausgaben für dialyse erst noch
durchsetzen
und wir damit zu rechnen also mit 90 530
und nicht mittels und der versicherung
straße war erreicht hat durch die
unterstützung ist aber die schwierigen
zeiten mit gangster quasi im krieg ist
franziska bevölkerung auf hilfe und
unterstützung angewiesen verletzlichsten
fraglich
[Musik]
für nach kurzen moment wird und der frau
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
schweizerische rote kreuz die sogenannte
kinder zu organisieren kriegsgebiet
befinde rolex und outtakes court der
unteren markt gesundheitlich
angeschlagene teams aus ganz europa 180
musikern 750 jahr über genfer schweizer
familie aufgenommen worden
[Musik]
der akt von menschlichkeit ist
international gut aus
[Musik]
am grenzbahnhof buchs war anton pertl
aus achtjähriger bub bis 105.000
kriegszerstörte viren etc
das ist die original tafel von 1945 die
sie damals fragen uns natürlich ja
daran waren hat man die kinder erkannt
wie war es damals ja also von
bequemlichkeit mal kleine rede der
schweier kalt war binder musste ich sein
sonst hätte sonst hätte ich nicht kommen
ja es war schon ein mulmiges gefühl und
es bedenken
mit acht jahren die trennung von den
eltern ist nicht ganz einfach
ja
aber es hat eine weile gedauert bis man
den trennungsschmerz über uns
[Musik]
hier parkplatz auf diesem parkplatz soll
sich seinerzeit das barackenlager
gefunden haben
wo alle 500 aus meinem zug damals
aussteigen mussten und wird dort ja
entsprechend behandelt wurden von den
schweizern das heißt das wichtigste war
dass entlassen
[Musik]
wir sind von einem schweizer arzt
untersucht worden aber eine absolute
respektsperson
er hat mich mit den worten begrüßt wie
heißes ding und das hat mich schon so
verschreckt dass er das drei mal fragen
musste bevor ich meinen namen und gesagt
haben
wir sind der von rotkreuz schwestern
betreut worden
wir haben uns ja das essen gegeben
nachdem wir hier ab gefüttert worden
sind hat der transport sich dann geteilt
mit so einer bin ich dann weitergefahren
lac st gallen und in st gallen ja bin
ich dann in empfang genommen worden von
der pflegemutter sammer forderte die
muppets die arzneimittel pflegemutter
instrumente daheim
die war ein äußerst verschreckt das kind
ich glaube durch die bombenangriffe so
geschädigt dass sie einfach ich habe mit
dem parlament verloren
war irgendwie in mich zurückgezogen und
habe alles über mich ergehen lassen als
halter kommt
[Musik]
bin erst langsam aufgebaut dann beim
einer pflegefamilie
dort hat sich dass diese angst ist
dieses schwache ja ja ja ja brüllte 88
du bist das ist mein kinderausweis den
musste ich haben um in die schweiz
einreisen zu dürfen
von der schweizer botschaft in wien
ausgestellt
dass der sex erholung wie sie die
schweiz unterhalten kann man schon sagen
muss ich kann fast sagen sie haben das
leben gerettet
im übertragenen sinn schon habe
gesundheitsprobleme gehabt
ja erstmalig gehabt also die ganzen
mangelerscheinungen
also haben wir sackgasse steckten zuerst
richelsdorf temax ja das ist wahr das
allergrößte thema
das hat sich praktisch alles darum
gedreht wie kann ich das essen für den
nächsten tag auftreiben
die mutter hat dann nach hause
geschrieben zu meinen eltern
also ich hab so gut zugenommen an
gewicht also so gut war ich dann eine
gewisse das ist ja einfach denkt nach
dem krieg das ein luther der warnrufe
dir doch wirklich da sind negativ vor
allem anders als man es nicht mehr so
schön wenigstens versuchen aber es zu
bedienen sind
[Musik]
gastfamilie und drehen sie häufig an die
beziehungen stammen
die regel nach drei monaten aber wieder
müssen abschied nahm wood knarrt und mit
ihr die heimat zurückgebracht
[Musik]
für die humanitäre aktion hat kinder
hier vom schweizerische rote kreuz aber
frau mit schweizer und ausländer bringen
ist aber auch politisches kalkül stangen
der bundesrat sauber hätten als köpfe
voller die kinder zuvor privater
hilfsorganisationen zu benehmen als
propaganda grund die geschichte zweier
historikerinnen antonia schmidlin und
elena comeback die kinder zyklische
natur schützen ist ihr handy kann man
sagen dass die anderen landes sonnig
nein nein das ist eine eigene spezies
von der schweiz die schöne tradition ist
intersport gründer torte eine der
initiatorinnen ich mattierende
paravicini xiii und 80 zentimeter nach
hinten wir einfach mal sagen dass es gar
als im gries geschädigter kinder gesehen
die weniger schöne sitte nicht als die
jüdische aber eigentlich mit dem
ausbruch von seuchen auch etwas mit den
usa waren etwas bestimmen
das hatte und das rad und die
fremdenpolizei
das ist der höchste fremdenpolizisten
blick sagt ich lasse mir die schweiz
nicht
und plötzlich maniche gegen die
überfremdung nach dem ersten weltkrieg
und die ganze gesetz gegen fremde länder
und warum herr zach schweizerische rote
kreuz war 2 400 organisationen bereit
warum hat sich das rad mitgegangen
erklärt unsere tradition muss
das ist tragisch war damals ist das rote
kreuz einer militärorganisation von von
hohen offizieren
damit der militärarzt regierungsrot
ruetz faktisch übernommen da hätte ich
auch die offizielle neutrale politik
korte und jüdische menschen zurück wie
sein obwohl theus bereitschaft die
bevölkerung groß sie war mit golz archiv
schicht von eth cilli hier sieht der
inneringer vor krankenschwester friedel
ruf bewahrt als freiwillige hetze warten
regina internierte lagert südfrankreich
schaffen im auftrag von roth tritt
das ist ein ganz wertvolles dokument
dass ich das fotoalbum von friede im
lager result sie 18-sieg mancher
internet ziehen
friedel reiter hetzte alltag im lager
mit ihrer fotokamera dokumentiert die
unteren ins spanische
bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge roma und juden
[Musik]
sie hat das ganze wahnsinnig erleichtert
miterlebt und hat sie aus allen ihren
kräften tag und nacht nur hoffen
[Musik]
sie hat den güter- dass es ist sie hat
für die hygienische oder quasi
hygienische verhältnisse sorgt und sie
hat später aus die deportationen 142
abfangen
auch die mit gerettet
[Musik]
ihrem tagebuch hat sie ihre innersten
gedanken und wie oft dort oft befällt
mich ein schreck die wir hier sind und
fast noch mithelfen bei diesem
menschenhandel kann niemand dieses
langsame morden aufhalten
[Musik]
sie hat sie redner dürfe und das hat sie
trotzdem gemacht und zur zeit klar
verboten und hätte sanktionskurs ja das
hat man alle grüßt aber sie hat in einem
interview gesagt dass sie immer kicker
sie haben betrogen sie haben papiere
falsche - sie hatten keine angst dürfen
sie hat den gegnern in die augen gelegt
obwohl sie angst gehabt aber sie hat die
retter werden
und das hat sie auch machen
die menschlichkeit im offizielle waren
und bitter verantwortlichen vom roten
kreuz sucht der strecke blieb trotz
damit drittel reiter zusammen mit
anderen auf hunderte von jodtabletten
n-tv ist margot wicke schwarz schild die
familie ist 1904 deutschland aus
südfrankreich verschleppt worden
bruder vater judisch eher zufällig
packte foto im rucksack für ältere
schwester und der unerschrocken
hartnäckigkeit von friedel reitet
erzielte schlappe zu danken
das ist original bild vor der erst kommt
nun von ihnen mutter also das bild
rechts geräte von apple kriegt herr rost
umgangen ich wo denn die masse
deportation anfangen das ist schon
besetzt einen benziner 42 sie mir oft
durch lichte standort zur deportation
die ganze familie und friedel reiter
hätte das gewiss dass mir auf der liste
stimmt und ich stehe mitten älter mit
dem bild zum kommissar der krippe seite
könnte frau sie ist erfolgreiche
christlich und die kinder sind out auf
und bat darum dass er uns die ganze
familie vor der realistisch trinkt und
das ist für mich kein dokument das ist
einfach das bild ich sehe schon dass sie
das könnte sie unter dass sie das sind
und sie sich hin und her gegangen und
den mit der tt rings zeit gut nennt sie
die frauen sind ab der mann muss mit
und das ist sicheres todesurteil von ihm
fertig sind und dann haben wir uns steht
direkt mit mir so verabschieden vom fax
vom vater und das bild ich es immer
bleiben wenn er sich entfernt von der
masse lied wonach stande sind und wie
mir gelingt hand und wenn er mit dem
koffer verschwunden ist es ist ein blick
der vater ist im konzentrationslager
auschwitz und braucht wurde
[Musik]
in den 50er jahren herzlich barcode wiki
schwarz schild auf zurück macht nach
ihrer lag mit einer großen blumenstrauß
geschenkt stück 7-sieg absuche in ihrem
fuß und wir sind ein land mehr als
fallen und es jetzt natürlich bestens
erinnere und mehr sind so voller
dankbarkeit sie wenn ihr wirklich ums
leben ihr zu verdanken
was ist passiert dort möchte die teams
klar dass das ja gar nicht die
offizielle schweiz ist sie bei euch im
grunde noch gerettet sondern das ist die
initiative vor
foxi war einfach gefunden hat das machen
das ist denn ein schock sind und ihr
stell ich mir eigentlich aufgegangen
dass es zwei sachen geht auf deiner
seite
die behörde die offizielle schweiz und
andere humanitäre schweiz die ganz
private personen botschaften und wo uns
kurzerhand und wo uns eigentlich denn
durch verbuchten trotz und
zusammenschluss mit dem mächtigen 2
das bündnis war polster vor jüdische
bevölkerung gegangen ist
für das verhalten und versöhnen sich
entschuldigt und geschichte kritisch
aufgearbeitet zeit mit der direktor vom
rot trotzdem markus mahnte aber der
aktuelle selbstständig geschützt
sie ist die ludwigshafener oder vor
offizieller organisation
im wege gebiet ist das ein werbefilm ist
für das internationale publikum ganz von
den ganz kleinen aspekt total iker
romero anderen autos wirken das thema
gemüse aufgearbeitet fonds überhaupt
schweiz das ganze gemacht und wo die
öffentlichkeit bevölkerung noch gar
nicht interessieren sie schätzt schützt
im thema knopf und herthas aufgabe und
heck musik gefunden und süchtiger sicht
nahe dem viel zu wenig gemacht meinte
dass für das entschuldigt und beteuert
dass das haben wir gemacht auffielen
die software arbeitet geschätzt erzählt
er sei überhaupt nur bemühen zu sehen
war und auch innere um system lernen und
mich an öde komplexität wie sie zu dem
zeiger innerhalb von ganz kurzer zeit
das ist schlicht ich damals eine techno
da sie dem fall phoenix fielen nach
olfen event vertreten
das wird nötig eine dose das ist möglich
dass hummer oder das geht mir ganz viel
gelernt erklärte stone abhängigkeit ganz
ganze wie ich die die studie
abhängigkeit als einfach ist ein
wichtiger grundsatz und das leben der
unserer nähe zum staat für alle
gesellschaften unseren ried zum start
sind mir rüber kam
in zivil unabhängige mission die
rückwärts grund sie ist in der stadt der
50er 60er und assistent an sich ist aber
[Musik]
vertraulich dialog mit der behörde
player und gleich zieht die konsequenz
stellig beziffert wurde von
menschenrechtsgruppen
[Musik]
neulich war die outdoor
ala die villa austria das ist neue der
helm vor der 12 zum asylzentrum
das nehme ich das ist schwierig
das gilt schon aber da hast du mir
sachen das ist hier ist frau tina du das
ist ihr zimmer dass hierauf macht
braucht ihr keine elektrizität den
charts sogar die blumen heißen euch
willkommen
herstelle vorige der nachrücker
sie wollen dann auf grand prix niveau
liege und eine super wahl presse
es sind zwei teams sind auch schon der
frankenthaler pro monat und bis zu zwölf
personen in der wohnung von der awo das
heißt wir sind super rhythmus unseren
maximum
grundsätzlich kommen das instrument wird
maximal stamme aber das könnt ihr schon
so selbstverständlich sind
es ist es euch dann schwierigen immer
irgendwas nicht wahrscheinlich dass man
es nie allen recht machen unseren zu
strahlen dass ich den mädels als
schweizer des roadster auftrag die
personen wo ist so etwas erwartet
unterbringen und der mit der unruhe mit
übernahmen und bezahlbar ist
dann dürfen sie mit unterschreiben
dank vier mal einfach im moment müssen
sie sich absprechen
mobiliar dass der ausbau wurde was wir
also mobiliar ist die rache dann
vielleicht man schnell wenn möglich
schon wieder veraltet sein dass möbeln
auch das genau wo sich der stein bildung
genutzt das warum stellt sie sich vor
sie sitzen im kreis center 80 sprachen
miteinander und danach
und so war es auch im internet die sich
immer noch arbeiten kannst du ich racker
anzahl und echtem er ist organ brüderle
hatte nach ausbruch stelle also den
zebras überhaupt aus ich konnte mir die
entlohnung nach nachdem sie sagen noch
nach noch ein grundbedarf start der
grundbedarf verliehene stufe dass es
wohl steckt oder ob die zeit wo man sich
gemütlich 10 17 58 uhr im lager mit
gespendetem bringt man falsch aus
das ist eine schöne dichte mit ihnen
gefallen naja das danke ich doch noch
geplatzt weil terenzi und sie werden
zusammen
das mache na ja das ist er
werk machen verdacht dass ich glaube ich
war glücklich die frage stellt sich 188
ich finde diese art in europa voran aber
es sind wirklich toll it was es wollte
schritt schaffen
das ist so sind alle speziell und heißt
es speziell sind alles nicht ob man
vergaben hängt ja ich denke also ich
richtig gut da schwingt sie auch die tat
mit oder die einfach zu managen und
manche garten heißt ja nicht dass wir
einen etat mit sondern manche garten
heißt mensch das kaliber es ist zu
respektieren so wie sich alle dass wir
mit aller motive stammen aber ohne dass
man auch nicht vor allem anfang auch
schon was ich sage oder beruf teilen
umstritten sonst keine persona wie es
ist
wir haben seid ihr zufrieden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in schluchsee und blieben es politisch
nicht opportun ish und menschen auf der
flucht aus betrug warten
[Musik]
der oberste grundsatz vom rotkreuz wird
heut zukunft immer wieder müsse bewahrt
[Musik]
dort wurde präsentiert von toyota hybrid
braucht keine steckdose und fällt
trotzdem elektrisch